we're seeing the real life impact of
those 13 years of failed government when
it comes to the extremely High Cost of
Living our crumbling public services and
our streets that are less safe
ultimately of course labor does take
responsibility when there have been
feelings you know I've been determined
as has care to make sure for example
that we rooted anti-Semitism out of the
labor party we've taken decisive action
to do that we see that impact of those
13 years of conservative government
right now in streets up and down our
country and the elections on Thursday
are a chance for people to see whether
they believe those 13 years of work for
them and their families or whether they
haven't
but if if you've been successful in
rooting out anti-Semitism in the labor
party how come it was only two weeks ago
that Dan Abbott had to apologize for for
a letter that she wrote
well actually again you see the
difference because immediate action was
taken it was napauling letter and it's
quite right that labor immediately moved
to suspend Diane Abbott there's no place
for such views to be propagated by any
individual and that's why reacted
speedily and decisively
but more broadly that this inflammatory
style of campaigning are you comfortable
with it on the run-up to the local
elections
well I think actually it reflects what
we've seen taking place in our country
you know I've been speaking with people
from Swindon to Sunderland over the last
few weeks and talking with people about
for example Community safety what's
actually happened to them to their
families the fact that increasingly
criminals are getting away with crime
some of the most heinous crimes
including in that no I work particularly
on women inequalities issues obviously
if you look at what's taken place with
domestic violence we've seen reports of
domestic abuse doubling since 2015 and
convictions actually halving during that
time something has gone badly wrong and
it's absolutely right that Rishi sunak
is held accountable for that as the
leader of the conservative party but as
as kirstama therefore should be when he
was director of public prosecutions but
for people that didn't go to prison for
committing crimes well actually
kirstarmer as DPP took enormous action
to deal with criminals to make sure that
there was tough action and in fact you
know I've seen some of the people who he
worked so hard to protect who've been
very clear that he went the extra mile
within the legal parameters that existed
at that time to get Justice for people
and that's been particularly the case
with women you know some of those who he
supported after they're being truly
appalling cases of stocking for example
sustained abuse and Care staffer was
determined to take action then that's
why he's so clear that when labor comes
into government we're not going to have
just a short-term sticking plaster
gimmicky approach to rooting out those
kinds of crime we're going to have a
mission that will have violent crime a
long-term Mission and that will include
having violence against women and girls
he's really determined to achieve that
change change
um you're announcing today an
announcement about housing what the
labor party is going to do to try and
help people get on the housing ladder
have more stable accommodation generally
last couple of days you've announced
helping renters by arriving targets to
build 300 000 homes a year
UK government hasn't really managed to
do that since the 1970s how on Earth are
you going to do it
well unfortunately we've seen really
things going backwards very very
speedily since decisions taken by Rishi
sunak and the conservative government so
we've seen obviously many people's
mortgages going up massively that 500
pounds a month conservative penalty for
many first-time buyers because of the
disastrous money budget last year but
we've also seen because of Rishi sunak's
decision driven it seems by trying to
appeal to conservative members to rip up
those targets as you said we're now
likely to see the lowest levels of house
building actually since the second world
war this is a terrible situation how are
you going to get 300 000 homes built a
year a year it just was an extraordinary
number
well two things we're going to focus on
to push up house building again the
first thing is a really important one we
know that economic instability
particularly the many budget but other
decisions taken by the conservators
they're really not confident out of the
house building industry we will have a
stable approach to managing the economy
Rachel Reese has set that out time and
again with clear fiscal rules and that
will create that much more stable
economic context and secondly we would
not be scrapping that Target as of issue
sunak did with nothing to go in its
place we'll work with local areas make
sure that we have those targets that
reflect local need that will then drive
house building in those areas you know
people really need to know the people
who don't want you know big housing
developments on their doorstep you know
dub nimbies but are you essentially
saying that they're just going to have
to suck it up that these homes will be
built
well we need to see a planning system
that actually responds to local needs
you know we've sent that out time and
again and again the conservatives have
been really unclear here about what they
want to do around planning they
suggested that local communities would
have no role in planning at one point so
planning does need to produce those
communities that are stable that work
for local areas but now let's just think
about the reality for so many people in
housing need right now we've already got
a situation where people are paying a
record amount of their income after tax
in rent 42 on average of people's income
after taxes going in to the cost of
their rent that's a huge amount we've
got the age at which people are able to
buy a home going up and up and are under
the conservatives it's now at 33 years
old the average age at which people are
able to start getting on the housing
ladder for those who can and increasing
number is simply not or even to look at
that as a possibility okay we're in the
middle of a cost of living crisis the
government should be doing everything
they can to support people right now
they should be freezing council tax of
course as well as laborers said we would
do but they should also focus on those
housing costs
very briefly before before we go will
you be paying homage to the king while
watching the Telly next week will you be
joining in with the oath
I will be personally because I think
that the king and all of those working
with them have been really determined to
create a ceremony that's going to be
very inclusive you know I think it's
wonderful there's going to be
representatives of different faiths
taking place that's going to be
representatives from all parts of the
country and quite a lot of you know
everyday Heroes as I understand it
involved in that ceremony and I think
we're all Keen really to commemorating
this momentous occasion together do you
think you'll be celebrating on Saturday
these local election results because
there's concern that the uh what we're
seeing in the opinion polls might not
necessarily be borne out the day before
on Friday
well actually we've got really a
situation that varies up and down the
country in these local elections 2019
was the last year when we saw these
Wards going up for election of course
that was an absolutely catastrophic year
for the Tories you know precipitated
Theresa May being forced out of office
so if they're not picking up seats
that's going to be a big big problem I
think for the conservatives they'll be
asking why do they've appointed Rishi
sunak as the new leader for labor though
it is quite different you know we didn't
have that kind of a completely
catastrophic situation we have got
different Dynamics in different places
but I'm looking forward to us picking up
support in those areas that we need to
win on the road to a general election
you know I think when people hear about
Labor's choices the fact that we would
be cutting the cost of living we would
be cutting crime we would be cutting
waiting lists actually they do want to
be supporting that change in communities
up and down the country